So let's begin with the very first cycle, cycle one. In this cycle there is
nothing to dispatch and nothing to write of course. So the only thing that we
really need to be concerned with is issuing an instruction. The load will look
at the reservation stations and look at basically the load's RQ in this case.
And see that there is an empty space there, so we can issue. So, we will
mark that this instruction gets done in cycle one, as far as issue is concerned.
Now, we have a busy load store Q entry. The operation is a load.
Now, the load uses an address. It doesn't really use a value. So,
in this case we will use our R2 which is 100. And add 34 to it.
And that address will be computed before we put it in the load queue. So
let’s say that this value is noted here as 134. So this is really the address.
We are not waiting for anything, but this load will produce a floating point
value and put it in F6. So we need to rename F6 to point to Load 1.
And the load doesn't dispatch in the same cycle because we said that we cannot
do that. So this kind of concludes the issuing of this load. Now let's look
at the second cycle. In the second cycle, we will try to issue this load and
there is a free unit, so we will do that. It's 45 from R3, so it's going to
be 245. Again, this is done by the address unit. It's not done by the ALUs or
anything. So this addition gets done immediately. And we are not waiting for
anything because a load doesn't really need to wait for
an, any floating point registers. And then,
F2 is where we're going to put the result. So we're going to mark this as LD2.
And this is it as far as the issuing is concerned in this cycle.
We will, dispatch, this load now. So its execution begins in cycle two,
because everything is ready for it. And now, we need to consider, okay, so
it takes two cycles to do a load. Does the write back happen at the end of
the second cycle or does it happen in the cycle after that? In this case we
will assume that the write back happens after the execution is done.
So the execution of the load will be done in cycles two and three. And the write
back will happen in cycle four. So we will kind of know, that basically we
will be able to write in cycle four here, just to kind of remember that